we've all experienced the benefits of
crowdsourcing
whether it's restaurant reviews that
help us find perfect place for dinner
or crowdfunding to bring our favorite tv
show
back to life these distributed
contributions combined
to make some super useful tools what if
we use that same concept to build
better machine learning models stay
tuned to find out
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning
i'm priyanka vergaria and on this
episode we are going to examine
a different approach to machine learning
standard machine learning approaches
require
centralizing the training data into a
common store
so let's say we want to train a keyboard
prediction model based on user
interactions
traditionally we implemented
intelligence by collecting
all the data on the server create a
model and then serve it
clients all talk to the server to make
prediction
the model and the data is all in one
centralized location
making it extremely easy but the
downside of this centralized setup
is that this back and forth
communication can hurt the user
experience
due to network latency connectivity
battery life
and all sorts of unpredictable issues
one way to solve this
is to have each client independently
train its own model
using its own data right on the device
no communication necessary
great idea right well not quite because
each individual device does not have
enough data
to render a good model you could
pre-train the model on the server
and then deploy it but the problem with
that is in our smart keyboard example
let's say if everyone started using a
new trendy word today then the model
trained on yesterday's data
won't be as useful so what should we do
to utilize the goodness of decentralized
data
while maintaining users privacy well
that's where
federated learning comes in the core
idea behind federated learning
is decentralized learning where the user
data is
never sent to a central server so
how does it work well you start with a
model
on the server distribute it to the
clients
but you can just deploy to every client
because
you don't want to break the user
experience you will identify these
clients based on which ones are
available
plugged in and not in use then
also find out which ones are suitable
because not all clients will have the
sufficient data
once you've identified the suitable
devices we can then deploy the model to
them
now each client trains the model locally
using its own local data and produces a
new model
which is sent to the server the thing to
note here
is that the data used to train the model
on the individual device
never leaves the device only the weights
biases and other parameters learned by
the model
leave the device the server then gets
all the locally trained models and
averages them out effectively creating a
new master model
but how do we know that this process is
doing something meaningful
and actually creating a good model doing
this once is not enough
we have to do it over and over so the
combined model becomes the initial model
for the next round
and with every round the combined model
gets a little bit better
thanks to the data from all those
clients and many many rounds later
your smart keyboard begins to show signs
of intelligence
now we just saw that all the training
data remains on your device and no
individual updates are stored in the
cloud
for additional privacy in federated
learning we can use the concept of
secure aggregation
where the server pairs up devices with
others in a buddy system
for example here each device has two
buddies
data from each device can be combined
with the random values
before being sent to the server the
server obviously knows the values sent
to the buddies and cancels them out
to just get the payload this trick
obfuscates the data
while in transit to the server if you've
used google keyboard
the g board then you have already seen
and experienced a federated learning use
case
when gboard shows a suggested query your
phone
locally stores information about the
current context
and whether you clicked the suggestion
federated learning processes that
history on device
to suggest improvements to the next
iteration of gboard's query suggestion
model
in this episode we learned that
federated learning is a collaborative
and decentralized approach to machine
learning that allows for smarter models
lower latency and less power consumption
all
while ensuring user privacy federated
learning is still a relatively new
concept and there's definitely more to
come
in the future i would love to know some
of the federated learning use cases that
you're thinking about
drop them in the comments below and i
look forward to seeing you
on the next episode of ai adventures in
the meantime
if you've enjoyed this video click that
like button and subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right when they
come